Hey guys, how's it going? So I wanted to
give you an air pods update. I've had them
for over a week now I have a lot of
complaints especially on twitter because
I was kind of just making fun of them
for the sake of making fun of them
because they're so easy to make fun of
but all things considered they don't
stay that well in my ears but they do
stay well enough if I'm not doing
anything super super crazy I made a
video talking about air pods on the
plane which was basically only a 30
second clip inside of a 20-minute vlog
and people got very upset about it. I'm
sorry I wanted you to see the vlog so I
had a title it's something that I know
you would click. But this video I promise you
is only about the air pods but also I
will feature a couple other headphones
that i'm currently using. What I like
most about these is how quick they
connect to my iphone and to my mac so the
main downfall for me with these is
obviously the huge one that they don't
say that well in my ears but I think that's
a me problem, it's not an everyone problem
because of my complaining on Twitter
bunch of people said I don't have that
problem i'm able to work out i'm able to
do things that I normally would with any
pair of headphones and they do not fall
out so it really is a case-by-case issue.
A huge huge major flaw for me is because
they are bluetooth there is a slight lag
in audio what i'm using my macbook and i'm
editing. Now this isn't just air pods,
this is a bluetooth issue. There is that
small bit of lag, so if I'm editing something
that I need to be editing to music I
can't use these. There's absolutely no
way because the beat will be off and the
music that I'm singing to is not what
I'm actually hearing so when I am using these
and i'm editing to music I have to
actually use the waveforms so that I know
where the beat is so that I can edit and
make the cuts there because I can't rely
on what I'm actually hearing and editing
to because it's not gonna match up.
I am very excited though because these
headphones I think have been
discontinued for a really long time from
Bose. This is one of the first pairs of
expensive headphones that I'd ever
purchased years and years and years ago
but, since then, they were broken and I couldn't
find them anywhere they didn't have them
online. I didn't want to get a used pair
off ebay. I went to the Bose outlet and I
saw that they had these and I was like
(GASP)
What I like about these is they go over
your ears for whatever reason when I
have headphones that are really big and
over top of my ears they end up giving me a
headache or even the kinds that have like
the little holes in them that go over top
of my ears. I just don't like it actually
if i'm editing and doing something for a
lot of time I just can't have that on my
head. So these are one of the only pairs
of headphones that ever really worked
for me and I didn't want to get
bluetooth ones because I can't deal with
the lag so these ones are the wired
version. So this is what i'm gonna be
using to edit when I need to have things
plugged in. But if this is too big to
carry, these are Bose sport version which
I don't like as much but I did have to
change out these ear tips to another
pair that I found on amazon. They were
just the replacement ones. I think Bose
has changed something in the last like
year or two because these are not the
same sounding as they used to be. I feel like
the sound quality when I first got a
pair of these maybe 3-4 years ago it was
so much better and they stayed better in
my ears so they definitely changed
something and I'm not sure what it was
if any of you guys know let me know in
the comments. It could be because they
made these ones water-resistant and
that's really the only thing that I can
think of. But I do like that they have a
microphone built-in so I do a lot of
phone calls and conference calls so
these are the earpods to come with the
iphone 7 and I basically just kind of
carry these around as a backup because
there's been times where I need
headphones and I don't have them and I
don't have my dongle so these always do
come to the rescue.
They also don't stay in my ears very
well but they do stay well enough that I
can listen to music or if i'm editing I
can't use these because it's a lightning
cable and I have nowhere to plug this in.
Good thinking Apple. Good thinking!
So, all-in-all AirPods. The top things that I
like is there super small the design of
this little thing is just so compact and
so cool that I haven't even had to
charge these since I got them. And that's it
they just they just go in it's
automatically connecting to my phone.
They're so easy I don't even have to
think about anything. It's just magic. It
really does feel like magic. I can just
throw these into my bag.
It's super-small, don't have to worry about cords.
Don't have to really worry about anything except
losing them. The big downfall, like I said,
is they don't stay very well in my ears
and a little bit of lag when I connect them
to my computer and I'm editing. You also
can connect these to an Android or any
other device that does have bluetooth
but you do have to actually set it up
and make any changes using your iPhone
But as long as you have bluetooth you're able
to pair these and use them on any other
device. So that's pretty cool!
I'd be interested to hear how these work
out for you guys like I said especially
on twitter I heard a lot of people say
that they didn't work for them but then
a lot of people were saying they were
perfectly fine for me so I don't know
why you're complaining and I wasn't
really complaining, again I was just
poking fun because it's it's so easy to.
I do really like them. I mean this, these are my
headphones right here in this little
tiny thing. I don't have to worry about cords.
I don't have to worry about the cases I do have
to worry about charging it and I just
wish I wish so much
this was USB-C, because now basically
everything is USB-C and... except the iPhone 7's.
The iPhone 7S is gonna have to be a USB-C.
Like if it's not, I'm gonna throw a fit.
I'm going to throw an absolute fit.
It'll be a great youtube video but it's a
fit that I don't want to have to throw.
All right guys, I'm gonna let you go. I just
wanted to give you a quick update on what
I thought about the air pods and...
yeah that's all. Cool. See you guys later!
Bye!
Just bring the box. Just buy the whole box.
You might need a couple extra cause maybe some extra people
will come home
oh yeah get the napkins too, Bri.
Get those napkins
you gotta get this big serving platter
yeah you gotta get this big bowl for the pretzels!